hey this is presto Walker a convex
quadrilateral is divided into four parts
by its diagonals three of the areas are
two one and three as shown in the
diagram what is the area of the fourth
region denoted by X I want to thank
Garrett for sending me this problem and
it's solution can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
rather than solving this specific
problem I will solve a more general
problem in which the four areas are s1
s2 s3 and s4 I'll label the vertices of
the quadrilateral as ABC and D and I'll
mark the point at which the diagonals
meet as e in order to write formulas for
each of these areas we will draw
altitudes from vertices a and C two
diagonal BD from vertex a for example
we'll draw an altitude which has a
height of h1 from vertex C we'll draw
another altitude which has a height of
h2 we can now use the formula for the
area of a triangle to figure out the
areas of each of these regions for
example s1 is the area of a triangle
which has a base of de and a height of
h1 so s 1 will equal de times H 1/2
similarly s 2 is the area of a triangle
which has a base of B e and a height of
H 1 so s 2 equals B times H 1/2 we can
continue writing the formulas for the
areas of these regions using the same
principle now if you look at these
formulas and perhaps rearrange these
equations you'll notice something
familiar in these variables the
variables in the first two sets of
equations are exactly the same variables
in the next two sets of equations in
fact if you multiply the first two
equations you would get exactly the same
result as if you multiplied the third
and fourth equations so we end up with
the principle that s 1 times s 3 equals
s 2 times s 4 we can now take this
formula and use the specific numbers
from our original problem to solve for X
we substitute in our values and we end
up with X is equal to 6 did you figure
it out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can support me on patreon
or you could check out my books which
are listed in the video description you
can also catch me on social media either
at mind your decisions or at presh tall
Locker